we'll also expand access to trade school
something that's been really badly
missing trade schools so important work
based learning and vocational education
so important vocational when I was young
growing up I used to see vocational
school Edinson vocational school that
meant people with a great talent but a
talent different than history and math
and other things but they had the same
talent or far greater than many of the a
students have studied out of the things
vocational school great people great
talent and they do very well they do
very well through our pledge to the
American worker we've already made
available 16 million apprenticeships and
training opportunities for the jobs of
tomorrow to bring jobs and prosperity to
our most distressed communities we
created nearly 9,000 opportunity zones
that's been a great success a tremendous
Tim Scott of South Carolina is helping
someone which have already brought
nearly 100 billion dollars in investment
to neighborhoods where millions of
Hispanic Americans live and you see it
so many of you already today and
speaking with you you said what a
difference that made before the plague
from China came in you know what that is
it's the China virus before it came in
and hit us we achieved the lowest
Hispanic American unemployment rate and
the lowest poverty rate ever recorded
history of our country ever recorded and
we're getting back to it very quickly we
achieved the highest ever incomes for
Hispanic Americans and many other
American groups and communities we built
the greatest economy in history not only
for our country but for the world we
were number one by far China had the
worst year in 67 years they weren't
happy with what was going they were
going in the wrong direction and then
the plague came in but together we will
do it again and we will do it very
quickly and we're already doing it we
will achieve a swift full and complete
recovery for Hispanic
Americans and the Hispanic American
community and we're doing it very very
rapidly our strategy focuses on
sheltering the most vulnerable including
older Americans and nursing home
residents while allowing those at lower
risks such as young and healthy children
in many cases the the immune system is
so powerful so strong but the young of
the healthy to safely return to work
into school we have to open our schools
open our schools stop this nonsense we
open our schools Germany Norway so many
countries right now they're open the
schools are open and they're doing just
fine and they're opening in the fall so
we have to get our schools open Denmark
Sweden we have to get our schools open
and stop this political nonsense and
it's only political nonsense it's
politics they don't want to open because
they think it will help them on November
3rd I think it's going to hurt them on
November 3rd open your schools at the
same time we're unleashing the
scientific brilliance of our people we
have multiple effective therapies in use
already with more being developed and
you have to see some of them the results
are looking incredible and we were in
track to produce a vaccine in record
time and very very soon it's going to be
announced I believe very very soon so we
have therapies and we have vaccines
utilising these advances and the skill
of our doctors and nurses we have
dramatically reduced mortality rates we
have among the lowest mortality rate
anywhere in the world
done a great job whether it's
ventilators or anything you want to look
at testing we test so many people that
we have more cases everybody says we
have so many cases that's because we
test so many people were up to
approximately 40 million tests going up
to 45 very quickly so we have tests
other countries don't do tests like we
do so we show cases other countries
don't show cases but what we do have is
we have perhaps the lowest but among the
but perhaps the lowest mortality rate
death rate anywhere in the world and
that's a tremendous sign as to what
we're doing and what our doctors have
learned and the kind of things that
we're using it's been an it's an
incredible number statistically an
incredible number a policy of never
ending lockdowns month after month would
ultimately do more harm than good to
public health and so bad for our
children as a result it really is more
loss of life we can't do that we have to
get back now we did it right we save
millions of lives by what we did we shut
it down we save millions of lives
I put a ban on China heavily infected I
put a ban on Europe very early both of
them very early we saved millions of
lives now it's time to get back to work
a lot of people were against those bands
and now they admit most of those same
people admit that ban was the greatest
thing saved so many lives crucially we
realized that the health of a nation's
economy is fundamental to the health of
its people in the last two months we
have begun the fastest economic comeback
in history including an increase in
Hispanic American employment of more
than 2.1 million jobs
it's a record the Hispanic prosperity
initiative will help build on this
program I will be naming a leader of
incredible vision former lieutenant
governor of New Mexico
John Sanchez and I know he's here John
I'd love to have you come up and say a
few words please well thank you mr.
president
what an honor it is to be here with you
and everybody else here in our nation's
capitol let me say from a young boy who
grew up in absolute poverty the youngest
of eight kids with a single mother I
understand what it is for the challenges
facing all families but especially
Hispanic families in this country but
because of her leadership through
personal responsibility stay in school
get a good education
we have lived the American dream as a
young boy I used to go and search for
cardboard boxes out of the trash cans of
grocery stores because we didn't have
the souls mr. president on our shoes we
would hope and pray they wouldn't rain
sore the cardboard wouldn't melt on our
way to school here now almost 50 years
later I stand next to the most powerful
man in the world and the most powerful
city in the world at the White House
with all of you fine folks today I have
lived the American dream I look at my
brand-new black shoes that's the
American dream mr. president your
leadership when it comes to job creation
education reform choice when it comes to
education will allow this country to
fulfill its American dream I'm honored
to be here with you mr. president your
great leadership making America great we
stand with you we'll keep America great
under your leadership god bless you
thank you very much I'll also be
appointing the CEO and president of Goya
foods Bob Yunnan way please good
afternoon mr. president good afternoon
everyone it's such an honor and such a
blessing to be here in the greatest
country in the world the most prosperous
country in the world and we continued to
grow and that's what we're here to do
today our company was founded in 1936 by
my grandfather who left Spain at only 18
years old did not know where he was
headed but he was heading and looking
for opportunity and prosperity and he
found it in this great country today our
company is a multi-billion dollar
company with thousands of employees and
with facilities all around the globe we
have a tremendous group of what we call
the Garron familia Goya the Goya family
the great Goya family and these are
people I told the president earlier we
haven't gone back to work we never
stopped working because when I asked our
group our family this is going to be a
tough thing they said look Bob
if we don't do it nobody will and they
stood up and they worked and we
continued to work day and night to
provide much-needed food and nutrition
to this country today it gives me great
honor and by the way we're all truly
blessed at the same time to have a
leader like President Trump who is a
builder and that's what my grandfather
did he came to this country to build to
grow to prosper and so we have an
incredible builder and we pray we pray
for our leadership our president and we
pray for our country that we will
continue to prosper and and to grow
today I have an announcement to make
that the grande familia Goya wanted to
share with all of you there's a great
need today in food banks around the
country food is being depleted hopefully
as the summer ends we have new crops
coming forward but right now there's
there is a shortage so our employees and
some partners we have in the industry
wanted to donate 1 million cans of Koya
took peas and a million pounds of food
and these are all products made in the
United States steel from the United
States Steel Silvan containers producers
rice mill in Arkansas donating food our
farmers and again all of our products a
lot of our products are grown here in
the United States made in America and
we're very proud to give back to this
nation to the food banks which are gonna
be needing some of that important food
something that we do all year but in
particular at this special time we
wanted to make that gift so god bless
you all we hope that we continue to
prosper and grow in this great country
and give thanks to God thank you very
much thank you Bob thank you thank you
it's very nice we're also grateful to be
joined by future commission members
standing behind me Mario Rodriguez Steve
Cortez Lourdes Aguirre Hosea when tez
Cassandra Garcia Meade Chris Garcia hey
soos Marquez David Olli Rehn sua Alfredo
Ortiz thank you all very much for being
here thank great great group of people
we've just had a fantastic meeting
Hispanic Americans are cherished members
of our national family they have been an
integral part of building this country
throughout all of American history over
generations Hispanic Americans have
started countless small businesses
inspired our communities and served our
country in every way imaginable
as police officers service members
Border Patrol agents pastors teachers
and business leaders they're incredible
now Hispanic Americans are watching as
the cities they help build the
communities they help police the
businesses they created and the dreams
they pursued are being threatened by an
extreme movement that wants to tear
everything down at the center of this
movement is an aggressive effort to
defund the police if you can even
believe that to fund the police think
about that so sad sad think these people
are crazy they are crazy
which would inflict great harm on our
hard-working Latino communities great
great harm many immigrants came to the
United States in order to leave
countries where the rule of law had been
eroded and they don't want those same
conditions to be replicated here they
don't want them back they know what it
is firsthand they know what happens when
the police cannot protect the innocent
when the rule of law is destroyed when
justice becomes an instrument of
vengeance
hispanic-americans they know they're
hardworking Patriots who support our
police protect our communities and
believe strongly in the rule of law I
will stand arm in arm with a Hispanic
community to ensure that every child in
America can grow up in safety security
dignity and in peace we believe that the
timeless principles of the Declaration
of Independence and the US Constitution
are all shared and they have to be
shared in a big beautiful heritage of
all Americans whether you're a
first-generation American or a
fifth-generation American this is your
home American history is your history
it's about you it's about your families
about our country and the American Dream
belongs equally to you American heroes
inspire us all and their legacy Falls to
all of us to cherish and to protect and
to revere every American no matter your
background is entitled to a government
that puts your needs and your families
first Americans of all walks of life are
united by the same noble ideas and the
same fundamental designs for good
schools strong families safe communities
and abundant opportunity and I will not
rest until we have delivered this future
for every community not only the
Hispanic community which is doing so
well but every community in our land
together we will write the next great
chapter of the American adventure and we
will defend the greatness of America for
your children for your children's
children and for generations to come
before signing this executive order
which is such an important executive
order I'd like to invite secretary
divorcé to come up and say a few words
followed by administrator Carranza
please come up Betsy thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much mr. president for your
leadership on this initiative as you
have noted education opens the door to
prosperity and opportunity and Hispanic
students leister president you have led
in advancing opportunity for Hispanic
students by supporting Hispanic serving
higher ed institutions by expanding next
students by supporting Hispanic serving
higher ed institutions by expanding the
opportunities for charter schools by
expanding the DC Opportunity Scholarship
Program right here in the district and
there's still more to do because all
Hispanic students across our country
need to have the opportunity to choose
their right education fit they need to
have school choice we know this is
broadly supported by Hispanic families
80 percent of them support this notion
of ensuring their children and their
grandchildren have that opportunity so
thank you mr. president for your
leadership in ensuring that all Hispanic
students have that chance at the
American dream
thanks mr. president I can't believe I
blinked at you president Thank You mr.
president it's a tremendous honor to be
part of an administration so dedicated
to helping Latino entrepreneurs this
during this extraordinary time in our
country as the daughter of
first-generation Mexican Americans I
know firsthand how important opportunity
is toward promoting upward mobility and
enabling the American dream creating
opportunities is the central goal behind
the president's new executive order
establishing the White House Hispanic
prosperity initiative designed to help
Hispanic Americans reach their dreams
through innovative education and career
pathways under your leadership mr.
president Latinos
have been the fastest growing group of
entrepreneurs in the country and we want
to see that continue
hola soy Kavita Carranza administered
hora de la SBA es una North ser parte
del cabinet a delay administration trump
estado de cada ayudar a los Empress Aras
Latinos durante estos tiempos de feces
komui Hadi Padres mexicanos Americanos
sell low importante que esta near
oportunidades para alcanzar el Sueno
americano lameta del Presidente trom es
ayudar a los Latinos alcanzar su sueños
otra vez de la educación y Nova Dora y
Carreras por ESO is fundamental st Orden
head to toe v to executive para nuestra
comunidad recuerden la comunidad espanha
tiene un ali allah allah allah sba
yoon amigo en la casa blanca
y que se dareka an Westra comunidad este
presidente es una persona FINA
gracias Mike maybe he'd come up just in
saying a real quick word cuz it's about
you know like setting records out here
but come on this man is such a big star
now California you went in California
yeah you gotta be a Republican we have a
lot of Republicans winning in California
Mike I think please I hope so I think
it's the beginning of something great in
California personally mr. president
thank you for the honor of being here
today it's a it's a huge honor to be
here with my Hispanic brothers and
sisters leaders in your communities
leaders in your respective businesses I
am the American dream I am a first
generation American my dad immigrated
here from Mexico when he was nine years
old I had the opportunity to serve my
country in the US Navy flying the most
powerful
strike fighter jets in the world the f18
off aircraft carriers in combat
operations and now I'm sitting here as a
member of Congress on the on the lawn of
the White House so I'd like to just echo
the president's comments that now is the
time where we need to unite as Americans
and really realize what this fight is
all about it's about freedom it's about
liberties it's about fighting like it's
1776 all over again that's how real this
fight is so I'm proud to be here I'm
proud to be serving my country again at
this most critical time in our nation's
history and mr. president thank you for
your leadership
brothers and sisters thank you for being
here today you gonna thank you ben
Carson please come up just for a minute
say a few words Ben you've done such a
great job thank you very much Thank You
mr. president and thank you all for
being here today you know it's so
important the emphasis that you have
placed on opportunity and you asked the
White House Council on an opportunity
revitalization to look at those
communities that were particularly
affected in the coab at 19 and we looked
at that and not just the fact that there
was more hypertension and diabetes
obesity asthma but to look another layer
underneath that and to deal with that
and that's what we're doing under your
leadership and you know every single
person in our society is worth saving we
only have 330 million people it sounds
like a lot but it's a quarter of what
China has a quarter of what India has
and we're gonna have to compete with
them in the future so we need to develop
all of our people and your emphasis on
education and educational choice will be
the thing that really distinguishes and
liberates our people so Thank You mr.
president
so now I'm gonna go and sign a very
important document one that we've been
working on for a long time and I just
want to congratulate the Hispanic
American community credible people thank
you very much and God bless you all god
bless america thank you very much
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
[Applause]